لا أحد يحب هذه الرسوم حقًا وأنت تعلم
أنها مخفية، ولا
يعرف الأشخاص ما يدفعون مقابله حتى
تعرف متى يصلون إلى الفندق أو حتى
يتحققوا من كيف يمكن للأشخاص تجنب الاضطرار إلى
دفع هذه الرسوم جيدًا أولاً
الشيء هو أنك تعلم عندما تتسوق لشراء
تذكرة طيران، فقط افهم أن ليس كل
شركة طيران هي نفسها، كما تعلم أن شركة Southwest
قد تكون أكثر تكلفة قليلاً ولكنك ستحصل
على هاتين
الحقيبتين المجانيتين المسجلتين قد تبدو Spirit وكأنها
الأرخص ولكن عندما  أضف كل ذلك، فأنت
تعلم أن بعض وكالات السفر عبر الإنترنت
أصبحت الآن أكثر شفافية فيما يتعلق
بهذه الرسوم، ولكنك تعلم أنه بالنسبة لأولئك الذين
لا يقومون بفحص الحقائب، فقد يرغبون في السفر
جواً، وهذا أمر جيد بالنسبة لهم
لتلبية احتياجاتهم، لذلك نحن كمستهلكين  بحاجة
إلى تثقيف أنفسنا بشأن ما تم
تضمينه الآن، رسوم منتجع الفندق
تثيرني حقًا لأنها
زائفة جدًا، كما تعلم أن بعض الفنادق الآن
ستفرض عليك رسومًا للحصول على 100 نسخة مصورة
في مركز الأعمال مثل من
يستخدم مراكز الأعمال في الوقت الحاضر أه  لذا فإن
ما يمكنك فعله هناك هو أن تطلب
منهم دائمًا التنازل عن الرسوم، لذلك لا
يضر أبدًا أن تطلب منهم معرفة ما إذا كنت تريد التحدث إلى أحد
المديرين، بل إن الكثير من الفنادق ستسمح
لك بالدخول إلى تطبيقهم اه نزاع حول تلك الرسوم
اه وأنا أقول دائمًا إذا  أنت لا
تحصل على رسوم المنتجع الكاملة، لذلك لا تزال العديد من
المنتجعات الآن لديها
خدمات محدودة، كما تعلم من رغبتك، فلا تتردد دائمًا في
الاعتراض على هذه الرسوم وفي
كثير من الأحيان سوف يتنازلون عنها
لك ولكنك تعلم أنه لغم أرضي
هناك  العملاء الذين تحتاج فقط إلى
معرفتهم والتأكد من
عدم وجود رسوم منتجع في الفندق
الذي تحجزه لأنه يمكن
إضافتها بسرعة